[Music]  maybe I was one maybe I'm just food  group Justin Bieber goes on a drunk rant  in celebration of his sold-out purpose  tour the where are you now singer made  an impromptu appearance at 1 Oak  nightclub in Hollywood on Saturday ET  exclusively obtained the video in which  Justin got deep with the crowd after  falling back on the DJ booth while his  song sorry played Bieber insisted on  giving the club goers a speech but not a  Kanye length speech the 22 year old  encouraged the crowd to be individuals  [Applause]  then Bieber went on to talk about why  people hate on him  but I feel like a lot of the reason why  was so many who that hate on me this cuz  I'm just myself  we're gonna make bad decisions sometimes  all of this happened hours after he took  to Instagram to post this throwback of  himself and Selena kissing with the  caption quote filled  [Music]